joining us right now making his way to
the ballpark in seattle member of the
18-8 los angeles dodgers is one of our
favorites calling to the program once
again
justin turner how are you justin i'm
doing great how you guys doing
i am doing fine so um what is it like
playing
this year justin what's it been like for
you
yeah it's definitely different um
obviously
a lot of new protocols a lot of new
hoops that we have to jump through to
make sure you know guys are being safe
guys are
taking care of one another um and
looking out for each other
and and each other's health and then
you know once you get to the ballpark
it's just weird no fans is tough man i'm
i knew we had great fans in la and i
knew we always fed off their energy and
and what they brought every night but
you don't really
realize how much you enjoy playing in
front of people until
there's no one there so it's been a
weird season so far for sure so i mean
we at home are hearing sometimes crowd
noise get pumped into our feed watching
the games it really is
nothing in the stadium at all they're
playing nothing no music no walk-up
music no
or or there is sort of that stuff still
going on a little bit
no that stuff's still happening they
they they do have crowd noise going
um they do have the cardboard cutouts uh
like last night
for example in seattle by the way
seattle i think is leading
the league in cardboard cutout
attendance uh
is that right uh is that right yeah but
in that ninth inning
uh you know they cranked up the crowd
noise a little bit
guys in the dugout were joking uh saying
that we're we're playing the seahawks
and not the mariners
um but uh yeah there's walk-up music
there's crowd noise they've they put
some stuff on the boards in between
innings uh
something that the dodgers have started
to do um
you know they've had guys kids kind of
tape
um you know for example clayton kershaw
you know when they announced the lineups
yes his daughter callie will be
teaching today my daddy clayton so
there's they're getting creative with
some stuff but it's still
nothing will replace our fans uh it's
still not the same
well i mean and then just um have you
had a conversation
uh did dave roberts lead it off or did
you and the rest of the
locker room and your teammates in your
clubhouse have a conversation
about when you're not at work
about conducting yourself in a manner
that doesn't
maybe make vectors of covid be brought
into your world did you have that
conversation
at all as a dodgers yeah it's not just a
one and done thing it's an
ongoing conversation um we've had
several of them
and really you know what it comes down
to is you know
being responsible for yourself being
responsible for your teammates
and you know trusting that all the guys
are making the right decisions because
even though
you know you're doing everything right
and you're you know following all the
all the rules and being compliant um it
just takes one guy on the team to not do
it and then you know you
might see something that happens like
the marlins or uh
you know the cardinals so uh it's a
constant conversation constant reminder
you know be responsible be smart make
good decisions don't be selfish
and uh you know it's something that's
taking place almost on a daily basis
justin turner of the 1808 best in the
base
record in baseball currently los angeles
dodgers uh calling in
from seattle making his way to the
ballpark right now are you dressed in
your uniform or do you dress there still
are you like going like little league to
the game and you're interested no
no we uh go to the park and close
um and get dressed there locker rooms
are different now
there's kind of an expanded roster but
they're still trying to socially
distance us in the locker room so
what you'd see in a locker room now is
uh there's
every other locker in the locker room is
taken up and then in the middle of
locker room they brought in like
portable metal ones
and space guys out in the middle of it
so it's a different look in there
you know food rooms aren't open anymore
they're kind of taped off
and we have a couple dodger employees
who are back in the food room and you
have to ask them for anything you want
and they
bring it to you you go in the bathroom
every other urinal
is blocked off every other shower head
is blocked off
so everything's changed everything's
different
going into the ballpark for example in
seattle we have to enter in the ballpark
and center field now
and you basically walk outside the
entire time
through the bullpen in through left
field
and then you go down the dugout up to
the clubhouse they don't let you go
inside the building anymore so a lot of
things are different
a lot of things have changed um you know
after the game we don't need dinner at
the field anymore
we come back to the hotel everything's
boxed up
in a conference room and you get off the
bus go in the conference room the hotel
pick up your dinner
and then bring it up to the room and eat
by yourself so
uh you know a lot of changes i bet so
justin turner here
uh on the rich eisen show all right
there's a couple of things i want to hit
with you here
uh first things first the date of uh
tuesday
july 28th do you remember that day of
this year
justin do you know what day that is i'm
referring to
off the top of my head um i can guess
here's here's a hint
it's houston it happened in houston you
were in houston that yeah that night you
know that date
that date ring a bell yeah oh yeah did
you know
at all what was in joe kelly's uh dome
taking the mound that night at all
justin
you know i don't know what's in joe
kelly's dome any day
if i'm being quite honest okay
i do know i do know you know joe's a
competitor i do know that
he is uh notoriously
capable of throwing pitches all over the
map i think
uh they actually hired him as the guy
that drilled the bull in bull durham
um but uh yeah i
i have no idea what he what he was
thinking what was going through his head
that night um
obviously a lot of stuff happened yes uh
that's all all behind us now but
yes indeed um but you're a smart guy
you're a perceptive guy i assume you and
the dugout were
or you were you're standing out on the
field you're beginning to piece stuff
together
right you're beginning to piece yeah i
was uh i was out of third base yes
um you know during the during the correa
bat i think brantley was on second and
then after he struck him out
uh you know brantley was running the
third i've played against i've played
against mike for a long time and
he came over and we were kind of talking
while all that stuff was going down and
uh you know i wasn't really in the
middle of it i was just kind of
you know sitting back like watching you
know
a lot of times those things everyone's
just kind of running their mouth and
john and nothing really happened so
uh you know it wasn't ever really
anything to get too excited about at
that point
so basically from your third base
position
you did not see the facial expression
that kelly
delivered leaving the mound i imagine
until after the game right or did you
have a good view of that one
just no i didn't see it i didn't see it
at all i didn't hear it um
you know it it is pretty quiet in there
you can hear a lot of stuff i know the
the entire inning their whole dugout was
all over joe um yelling
you know i think dusty was calling him
skinny ass mf for the whole inning and
um so there was a lot of there was a lot
of john
chatter on our side before any of this
stuff even happened
uh and i think i think if you listen to
the john boy video you can actually hear
dusty yelling out a minute so
uh it wasn't it wasn't just uh you know
joe there
and i know i know dusty went on and said
that joe antagonized it but they were
they were all over on the whole inning
so
so i mean what what happened though
after the inning in the in
the dugout in the clubhouse afterwards
did did this in some way shape or form
bring you guys even closer together do
you think
as a team i under look and i understand
this is a sensitive subject because you
know
nobody wants a baseball in the head we
understand that but this is there's a
ton of
there's a there's a very large bridge
and there's a ton of water under it
you do have two more games against
houston in it coming up
uh in september in just a couple of
weeks um so
did this at all bring you guys you know
in a more cohesive manner together do
you think
yeah anytime something like that happens
i think it brings the guys
uh you know closer together and uh you
know we've had
a few incidences this year come up
um and you know when you
see that guys have each other's backs
and they're you know standing
shoulder-to-shoulder supporting one
another i think
it's huge for team chemistry if you
believe in team chemistry or not but
uh you know those those things do help
teams come together and
and you know we've been playing pretty
good baseball since then so and uh just
a last
question on this subject here did you
see trevor bauer's
shoes that he was planning on wearing in
major league baseball apparently told
him if he wore it he would get
uh he would not be able to play in the
game he'd be ejected and potentially
suspended or fond have you seen this
justin yeah i did see those shoes when
uh
you know that's that's another guy
that's you know not scared to speak his
mind speak his opinion
and uh personally i i thought the shoes
were great
um you know there's the t-shirts are
going around all over the place the free
joe kelly hashtag all over social media
i mean
i don't think uh they were supposed to
lighten the shoe rules this year and you
could wear whatever you want put
whatever message you want
and apparently unless it unless it
offends rob manfred
uh you can put whatever you want well i
guess so your your piece of metal shoes
is not going to be worn is that what
you're saying this year yeah i'm still
working on those i'm trying to find the
right shoe artist
i bet so man i bet so uh justin turner
here on the rich eisen show uh okay
and uh the other subject is sensitive to
my friend who's across the way here
chris brockman who's from uh
uh the new england area loves the boston
red sox so please do not hold back in
your answer whatsoever i really want
your
your unvarnished opinion of mookie betts
as a teammate and uh
what what he's brought to your your team
justin
oh man he is everything
advertised and then some uh
you know he his appetite for
getting better and working and not
taking things for granted is
off the charts probably better than
anyone i've ever played with
um almost almost it's almost funny uh
you know
being in the cage with him before the
game and watching him work
and it's like every swing he takes he
he finds something wrong with it he's
constantly tinkering
and he's a perfectionist and
i think that's what makes him so great
and since he's been
bumped up to the to the lead off spot uh
you know our offense is really taking
off
and he's a game changer he can set the
tone from the first pitch
what he doesn't right he's everywhere in
right field i feel like there's four
four mookie bets standing on right field
um it seems like every ball that goes up
he's camped under it somehow and
uh just a great guy great conversations
with teammates
helping guys out i know he's had a lot
of conversations there's been a lot
talked about
with him and austin barnes and barnes
he's playing really good right now so
um you know he's just a guy that you
want to have on your team and i think
la is very very fortunate to have him
for the next i think 12 years
if i'm not mistaken i think it was
seeger who was on the receiving end of
that throw in arizona from the corner
that he threw on a total
dart on the line right it wasn't you who
received that from third base
if i'm not i only received the credit
for it but no it wasn't me
okay i mean what what speaker when
you're when you're
watching that though in real time i mean
what in the hell is that
that i mean you want to talk about
freakish ability that is unbelievable
what he was able to do from russia yeah
uh
you know i i got the chance to play with
yatiel fueg who obviously has a
right you know tremendous throwing arm
and i was on the receiving end of his
throw in colorado when trevor story
tried to stretch and triple and he threw
the ball from the right field wall
essentially
in the air to third and that was
mookie's throw was
uh comparable for me you know he's going
to his left up against the wall spins
and fires a dot right on third base
uh just incredible i mean he's a freak
athlete
he's a perfectionist i think everything
that he does he's
really good at i mean he's a
i think a two handicapped golfer oh no
he's not
come on no 10 300 games bowling i mean
everything he does he's
he excels at he's he's good so uh
nothing
i don't think anything's going to
surprise me he's more so he's a seven
tool player is that what you're saying
i said i think it's like 12 i don't know
i mean
it's unbelievable and then you know the
to have the ability
he's got six three home run games in his
career that's just that's just absurd i
mean
that isn't
well um look justin i know you just had
a milestone hit of your own
thousandth career hit congratulations on
that before i let you go you and your
wife courtney
um have the justin turner foundation
together helping a ton of people in
southern california
i'll give you the floor on that what
you're up to how people can get involved
please uh yeah we're always
trying to do what we can and get back to
the city of la obviously they've
done so much for me and my career and um
you know our main beneficiary is the
dream center of los angeles they have
a ton of great programs going on over
there but the ones that were
you know we work closely with our you
know the veterans
homeless veterans program they have a
men's floor and a women's home um
getting homeless veterans off the street
helping them make that brutal transition
back into everyday life
and uh they just reopened their food
line again
um with la unified school district not
opening back up there's a lot of
families in los angeles who
depend on that hot meal program that
aren't going to have it because the
schools aren't open so
you know we've worked with local
businesses local restaurants
ordered food done some deals got some
food donated that goes up there and
families can drive through the line and
pick up hot meals
for three or four hours a day so there's
always good stuff going on up there
they're great people great leaders
pastor matthew barnett runs it and
we're happy to be partnered up with them
and and help in our community
in as many ways as we can and if you
want to donate to the foundation you can
go to justinturnerfoundation.com and
um all the information's on there justin
i really appreciate our chats
you've always been good to call into the
show whether it's the playoffs or now
obviously the regular season
in a unique uh campaign to say the least
i i greatly appreciate it and
um you know what i'd like to do uh maybe
to help the calls here
is my sound engineer from new jersey
mike deltufo
uh i'm gonna make a cardboard cut out of
him and put it in dodger stadium
just for yeah so the rich eisen show is
part of what's going on in dodger
stadium
okay hey listen we we we've led the
league in attendance every year we can't
we can't lose on the cardboard
attendance this year so throw it in
there i will do it i'm in yeah
trust me this is by the way it's
happening i'm i'm i'm not kidding this
is going to happen
so justin keep an eye out for that keep
an eye out for that all right i will
we'll chat soon thanks again
okay thanks rick you got it that's
justin turner hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here